all right great so my name is Rick
Hayden's I work for JW player first I'm
going to explain a little bit about our
data science ecosystem so we have a lot
of different services basically or
back-end is entirely built on a
service-oriented architecture all these
different surfaces store data in their
own data stores for example a lot of
services use Postgres sequel is a
database we use extensively use Amazon
s3 as data storage object storage then
we're in our data science ecosystem and
we do some processing on that data so
for example in we run jobs on EMR that
read some data of s3 usually in the
park' format and then transform the data
write it back to a3 again we do some
things with Kafka mostly real-time
pipelines we also doesn't change data
capture with Kafka so we monitor
databases for row level changes through
mother changes to Kafka and then we have
consumers within the company that then
read those changes and then perform some
operation based on the data that they
read we make extensive use of snowflakes
no plague is our data warehouse it's
where all the different data sets come
together and where we as a data science
team can join all the different data
sources together so for example we have
data coming in from Salesforce we have
data coming out of Kafka you have data
coming out out of Postgres databases
data coming from history when it's in
snowflake that's where everything is
variable and joinable and everything
else
there's also kubernetes in this slide
communities is very important its water
entire back-end runs on all our services
API set cetera run and kubernetes but we
also do a lot of data processing
processing on Cooper needs and that's
specifically what I'm going to talk
about next there there's also some cycad
learn and tensorflow that's those are
usually the libraries that we used to
do anything related to machine learning
so as you can see we have like all these
different things but how do we get data
from one place to the other and how do
we orchestrate all of that so that's
that's essentially what what what we're
going to solve before we jump into that
solution first a little bit about JW
player so birth open source video player
and platform and similar to let's say
YouTube but then for publishers and
we're headquartered in New York City we
have about 200 employees but also little
office here and ain't open with a couple
of engineers we're mostly a SAS business
so our customers are pretty well known
and are pretty famous publishers such as
in the Netherlands and the u.s. new
Dardanelle but also worldwide we have a
lot of customers euro sports pretty
famous yoona fishing i believe in latin
america we do about fourteen forty
billion plays every month through our
player which is about five percent of
all the online video plays and every
single month we ingest about a hundred
terabytes of analytics defense mostly
coming from the player so our player
since all sorts of defense when when
something happens so for example if
someone plays a video we get an offender
of that if someone watches the video for
a certain amount of time we get an event
of that and that accumulates to about
100 hundred terabyte of data every month
so the main difference between us and
let's say youtube is that we're a white
label solution we offer a lot of the
same services but we are always a little
bit in the background which is probably
also why you might not know us but yeah
the players present everywhere so one of
the reasons why you might choose us over
let's say YouTube is that we for example
don't take off your advertising
monetization income so the rest of this
talk and
to quickly reintroduce Apache airflow
then I'll talk about some of its
shortcomings and some of the things that
we have run into then our deployment
system which is built on top of
kubernetes which is important in order
to explain how we actually run the
workloads using heroine and we'll have a
short Brett respective so airflow
whoever you have went to let's maybe do
a show of hands who have you went to the
workshop yesterday from axle okay so
good I see that quite a few people have
been there so airflow is a platform to
order schedule and monitor workflows so
the idea is that your define your
workflows in Python code yeah okay so
yeah the ideas that when you when you
define your workflows in Python code
that they put become collaborative you
can version them you store them and get
you deploy them somewhere and there are
easily reviewable and so airflow is
built on top of a couple of course
concepts the most important comes up
being the directed acyclic graph the DAC
so the dag is essentially the collection
of all the different tests but you would
want to run so for example here we have
a dag with three notes in them which are
the tasks a can only run or B can only
run after a but so you can run at any
time then the operators are the tasks
the abstract test definitions in your
DAC so here I outlined B which is one
task in your workflow then once you have
these tags and these tasks they your DAC
for example also has some properties
associated with it for example when it's
set when it's supposed to be run so your
DAC can run on maybe every every day at
10 p.m. or maybe every every hour so
when that runs the
operators in the dag will be
instantiated and that's what what we
call it tasks so at that time we you can
parameterize certain things for example
maybe you want to run some tasks you
want to pass it an argument for example
the execution date for this task that's
what happens when you instantiate the
operator and that at that point you have
a task instance the task instance
represents that specific run of the task
at a certain point in time so by
combining the acts and operators to
create tasks instances you can build
really complex workflows so airflow
itself is consisted of a couple of
components so there's the webserver the
scheduler and workers the webserver is
the UI that you can navigate to everyone
who has been to the workshop has
probably seen that UI by now and the
scheduler is what looks at all the
different tasks that need to be run and
tries to figure out which ones need to
be run and then the workers are what
actually do to do the work so where your
tasks execute and then airflow uses a
database to keep track of all the state
about which tasks have been run what
they're and what they're but the state
of that was so a JW player we run all
these different components except for
the data except for the database and
kubernetes so the web server runs in
kubernetes the scheduler and the workers
and we use Amazon RDS for the database
because that that is easier than running
a database in kubernetes
so JW player we use airflow for a lot of
different use cases so we launched mr
clusters running PI spark in order to
process all the telemetry that we
received from the player we run queries
on our snowflake cloud data warehouse to
join data from our different data
sources in order to build reports and
we've run a lot of those reports on a
daily basis to inform or for example our
sales organization or just in order
internal reporting we have some products
that are powered by machine learning
models for example recommender
and or thumbnail selector we can use
airflow to
train and evaluate and then deploy those
models to production and yeah we do a
lot of different standard ETL workloads
are being orchestrated using airflow as
well so for us airflow enables our data
science team to operate autonomously
within our team even data scientists can
create their own workflows and they can
do their own data processing this is
really nice because you we are not
always dependent on another team in our
company for data we can just create the
workflow ourselves deploy it to air flow
and get it up and running and the nice
benefit of air flow is also the Attic
transparency so because we do all these
things within the data science team we
can just go to the UI see what the state
is and based on that we can figure out
like okay should data after you present
or not and do we need to take any action
so for example right now we're working
on a new product where we replace
aesthetic thumbnail for videos with a
video thumbnail so in order to support
an a/b test in order to figure out how
much that moves the needle in terms of
click-through rates for video our
product manager wants to perform an a/b
test so in order to do that we need to
change the job that essentially analyzes
the telemetry from the player that the
player needs to start start sending that
to us obviously but then we need to make
some changes to in order to support that
a B test then we basically have a table
in our data warehouse that has metadata
about thumbnails we have to make some
changes to that in order to figure out
whether this is a video thumbnail or not
and then we make changes to partition
and aggregate data for users in the
different variants of the a/b test such
that we can do that analysis and then
based on that analysis on that data we
have to calculate reports in order to
the result of the AP test is so all of
these different tasks need to be
orchestrated in some way and that's
where we really use air flow for so but
one mytab workflow look like so more
concrete here I have an example so we
have attack that runs on us on a daily
basis and this Dax goal is to aggregate
video plays for the analytics API so one
way that that you can do this is you can
launch an EMR cluster to analyze all the
telemetry that you get from the player
notice to count the number of plays per
video this this might be the first step
in your deck the next then after that we
can add another step that lost the
aggregates into our data warehouse after
which it is square able and then we need
some final tasks that then pushes those
results from the data warehouse to the
analytics API such that they can be
served so then at that point you have a
dag tree three separate tasks in there
so one problem with this is that so
one one thing that I must make clear is
that a lot of these ship with airflow
and they they basically perform some
your tests to some extent so this Emaar
create job flow operator is the thing
that ships with air flow and then makes
a call to Amazon in order to launch the
EMR cluster so to some sense air flow is
concerned with what your task is this is
a problem for us because it's the wrong
level of abstraction because these
operators are responsible for some piece
of your task execution the task the task
is really tied to the operator the
problem with that is that a for example
there's a bug in your in the airflow
operator
enter your are in your task and you need
to debug this that you not only need to
debug your own task but you also need to
figure out whether maybe that operator
is doing the right thing and that that
is that is really hard that just said it
has a really negative impact of the
availability of your workflows and we
don't really want that and
want to separate task orchestration from
task execution at which are at which air
flows not not ideal but we really like
it for its test orchestration
capabilities so what we did is we
already extensively used docker for some
building services we are using air flow
for workflow orchestration and we were
already using kubernetes to run our
back-end applications so we figured that
it would be a good idea to sort of share
that apart separate the concerns we're
making air flow responsible for other
tasks orchestration but then doing other
compute and kubernetes itself
so at JW player every task is a docker
container so the idea behind that is
that containers improve application
portability make it easier to release
new versions of a task provide some
current consistency guarantees like your
environment is always going to be the
same whether you run your container
locally or whether you run it on on yeah
on kubernetes so this is really nice
because at that point when your task is
defined in a container it can be treated
as a black box by air flow or flow only
needs to run it at some point it needs
to figure out when it can be run it then
runs it and it then has to wait for the
tasks result so it can either fail or
succeed this is a really powerful
concept so this is an example of one of
the DAX that we run internally in the
data science team so here we have some
tasks that create an EMR cluster and
then once that that job is done and it's
it has loaded data into the data
warehouse we have a bunch of other tasks
that then do something with the data
that was loaded so all of these purple
tasks we are running all of those in
docker and we make a few exceptions and
those are the really
wait tasks that are like one or two
lines of Python code or typically
sensors because it's a lot of overhead
to run a sensor and kubernetes so
airflow actually has a solution that
allows you to run your task sets docker
or containers but the way that it works
is that it just communicates with the
darker daemon which is nice but that
doesn't really work when you run your
airflow stack itself on kubernetes
because you don't get direct access to
the docker demon so we did actually use
this for a while when we were not
running airflo in kubernetes but yeah at
some point we migrated that over and we
have to find a different solution
so then AirFloss also comes with a thing
called kubernetes pod operator so this
is an operator and that allows you to
run paths and kubernetes from airflow
it's a really nice solution but that
also requires direct access to the
kubernetes api and unfortunately even
though we run everything on kubernetes
we don't get that at JW player or DevOps
team is really yeah sort of protective
about who gets access to what so we
needed something different and in order
to understand that solution I have to
explain what our deployment system looks
like so I could probably feel like a
30-minute talk about this but basically
the general idea is that we have
kubernetes and then we run some services
on top of kubernetes to manage
deployments in particular to services
are important for us and those are
gantry and Squealer essentially a gantry
is the tool that interacts with
communities that we get to interact with
and Squealer is the fan bus of the
deployment system so whenever something
happens in our deployment system we can
list listen to those events by listening
to that event boss
so Gantry manages our deployable
resources so it's a really thin
abstraction on top of the kubernetes api
so we can create deployments ingresses
jobs through it and cron jobs and
something that's also really nice for me
learning is because it's just a tin
abstraction and kubernetes we can also
use all these nice features such as
running jobs and GPUs and yeah again
free makes it easy to to create such a
job but in our deployment system school
or SD fan bus so anytime something
happens on kubernetes a message will be
published to this RabbitMQ if and bus
that that is managed by schemer and then
everyone can sort of connect to that
event bus and listen for a fan so for
example when you create a job on
kubernetes through gantry a message will
be pushed to that a fan bus and then
consumers can listen to that so you can
perform some action based on whether
some offense is going on on your under
cluster so yeah what we did is we took
this deployment system and we build an
operator that's analogous to kubernetes
pot operator that launches tasks as jobs
on this deployment system so the way it
works is that an airflow we have the
operator that talks to gantry that
creates the job so this entire
deployment system is all based off one
api's gantry dan goes and creates a job
on kubernetes we then start listening in
our operator to life cycle offense for
that job and once something happens we
act on that so for example the job
starts running then or operator knows
that the job is running and it starts
logging some output on air flows logging
slaughter logger so it's such that you
can track the state one thing that's a
bit tricky is that since your job now
runs on on a cluster which is not on
your local airflow instance like you
would usually do logging works a little
bit different differently
so we actually need to be able to get
logs from our job into air flow because
we would really like to be able to go to
the web UI and still be able to see
the jobs output which is really useful
if you're debugging so typically our
locks are just being standing into a
standard elastics Serge locks - Cabana
stack but for this operator we actually
interact with a kubernetes api method
rename space pod lock which is actually
the only exception that we had from our
DevOps team to directly interact with a
kubernetes cluster because it was a bit
of a hassle to get those locks in to
airflow from or ELQ stack so basically
what country jump operator does is that
it has this concept of a lock Taylor
once it creates your job and it has
detected that it's running it will
instantiate that lock Taylor and that
will basically start streaming the locks
from the kubernetes api back on to air
flows logger and then at that point you
see the locks in the in the web UI again
in order to support this operator we
have to make a number of changes to our
jobs basically when we when you run your
jobs on kubernetes you need to be able
to fetch your configuration from
somewhere so the configuration for all
our jobs are stored on history and we
had to change that such that jobs can
put their confess from history when you
start them or you need to be able to
read config from your environment
variables we had so malicious is the
secrets system or for deployment system
basically what it does is that it uses
super needy secrets the amount of gamma
file containing all the secrets that you
need in your in your job bot so we had
to change all our jobs to be able to to
read secrets from this format and then
lastly what's really important is that
on kubernetes exactly once execution is
not guaranteed this means that if you
create a job on communities that
transform some data then it is not
guaranteed that that will run only once
because when it runs on the cluster and
not could go down the kubernetes
controller will then detect there and
will then see that hey
just notice gun we need to rerun the job
somehow so we had to make sure that when
we move to this model that our jobs are
idempotent and this is really important
when you don't do this for example when
you have some job that inserts data into
a table and it doesn't check whatever
that data is already present or it
doesn't always overwrite the same
partition of that table then you'll end
up with double rows in your table and
your jobs not idempotent so we have to
put in a lot of effort in making sure
that this was handled correctly
everywhere but in retrospect air flow
enables our engineers and data
scientists to write complex workflows in
a self-service manner so data scientists
can write workflows engineers can do it
there's yeah the review process is
really lightweight and it's really easy
to get something up and running within
the data science team we can now use
this operator to leverage all the
features that you would simply get from
kubernetes so we can use air flow to run
complicated pipelines that train machine
learning models they fail you ate them
and deploy them somewhere
within the organization this system has
been adopted by multiple teams so it
started out as a project in the data
science team but yeah now our core data
team was responsible for all the
pipeline's that power products has also
adopted this model so internally
everyone is on the same stack now and
yeah it just has been really successful
for us yeah that was my engineering talk
about airflow any questions about this
setup or
you